and I understand that not being
vaccinated today I you know I'm unable
to travel to most of the tournaments are
you prepared to forgo the chance to be
the greatest player that ever picked up
a racket because you feel so strongly
about this jab yes if this means that
you miss the French Open
is that a price you'd be willing to pay
yes why no fact why why because the
principles of uh
decision making on my body are more
important than any title it's a really
evil question the way that it was framed
because he is the best male tennis
player of all time point is he has
conviction right I don't need this thing
and I am willing to do what is right and
it will cost me money it will cost me
treasure it will cost me accolades Fame
etc etc